[Música]
y
sí
[Música]
y
buenos días mi nombre mauricio hace de
dominio
me formé como médico cardiólogo acá en
la ciudad de córdoba luego me regresé a
mi ciudad natal a chajarí entre ríos
para ejercer mi profesión con el pasar
del tiempo empecé a ver lo que conocemos
que la primera causa de muerte en el
mundo los problemas cardiovasculares
infartos accidentes cerebrovasculares
pero noté cuando estaba trabajando que
tenía dos grupos de pacientes me venían
a ver pacientes con más de 70 años más
de 80 años que generalmente venían del
campo lo traía la familia y lo que yo no
estaba en estos pacientes es que
entraban a mi consultorio caminando me
entraban lúcidos entraban y me dicho le
preguntaba y por qué han venido no me
traen mis hijos para control entonces
imagínense como cardiólogo le pregunta
de cuáles son tus hábitos de vida cuál
es tu ritmo de vida que es lo que comes
y eso me decía mira mauricio nosotros
comemos lo que hay en el campo nosotros
comemos lo que tenemos
comemos huevos comemos manteca de campo
comemos cerdo imagínense hecho como
cardiólogo
cuidado con los huevos cómo vas a comer
huevo manteca pero yo me decían pero
mauricio 190 años toda la vida comía
esto pero tened cuidado mira si te pasa
algo a los 90 y así empecé a ver el otro
grupo de pacientes pacientes jóvenes
40-50 años que cuando me venían a ver
tenían factores de riesgo tenían
enfermedades sobrepeso hipertensión
diabetes gente joven y de repente con el
transcurrir de los años yo pasé a ser
parte de ese grupo de jóvenes con
factores de riesgo empecé a tener la
presión alta con el ritmo de vida del
acelere empecé a tener la presión alta
hacía deportes pero tenía varios kilos
de más entonces digo pero como yo soy
cardiólogo y ahora tengo hipertensión
soy parte de esta gente joven a su vez
empecé a recibir pacientes jóvenes con
esta segunda causa de muerte que es hoy
en el mundo según la organización
mundial de la salud que es el cáncer
entonces los pacientes tienen cáncer
cuando se van a operar viene a hacerse
un pre quirúrgico lo hacemos electro y
como médico uno siempre pregunta cuáles
son sus hábitos de vida
lo que comen y como cardiólogo les
recomendaba entonces le decía mujeres
jóvenes con cáncer de mama que es una
epidemia hoy en día como carl yo les
recomendaba pero no coman huevos no
coman grasa y me decían pero mauricio
nosotros no comemos huevos no comemos
gracias y hace
20 años que no lo previó en 30 años
luego comencé a llevar a mis hijas a la
escuela el mismo colegio donde yo iba
cuando yo iba a la escuela a mi hija
empecé a ver que en las escuelas de
argentina se repetían las estadísticas
que hoy tenemos a nivel mundial empecé a
ver que uno de cada cuatro chicos en la
escuela tiene sobrepeso u obesidad
empecé a ver que 1 de cada 6 chicos
tiene hiperactividad o déficit de
atención 1 de cada 9 con asma 1 de cada
11 con alergias alergias en la piel
alergias intestinales 1 cada 21 con
convulsiones entonces hablando con los
padres que los conozco leo pero cuáles
son los hábitos de vida que estás
haciendo de golpe mis hijas pasaron a
ser parte de ese grupo mi hijas vivían
enfermas empezaba el invierno
gastroenteritis broncoespasmo asma
neumonía vivía medicada entonces mi
señora que es médica nos preguntan algo
que como somos médicos y nuestros hijas
nuestras hijas viven enfermas
y entonces le preguntaba a los padres y
yo mismo me preguntaba que estamos
haciendo y le decía ojo que le estás
dando huevo a tus hijos no a mauricio
nosotros hace 30 años que no como el
huevo pero que comen manteca no comen
cerdo
alguien de ustedes comenzó hoy en día
esto sea y donde los pusimos pensemos y
si pensamos por qué por qué nos está
pasando estoy es ahí donde nos dimos
cuenta que la causa de todas las
epidemias actuales era la misma es la
inflamación la inflamación crónica
nuestro organismo está preparado para
estar inflamado pero de manera aguda o
sea voy de golpeadas te caes tenés una
lesión y este organismo reacciona para
solucionar ese problema pero de manera
aguda no de manera crónica no estábamos
preparados para estar crónicamente
inflamados y de cuando empezó esto en
los años 50 aproximadamente 60 la
principal causa inflamación era el
cigarrillo y los aceites poliinsaturados
pero en aquel momento años 50 60 70
estaba socialmente aceptado de que todo
el mundo fue entonces fumábamos si en
las reuniones con familia entonces
empezaron a aumentar los infartos los
accidentes cerebrovasculares y el cáncer
de pulmón pero como había intereses
creados y era una moda se empezó a
buscar cuál era otra causa vamos a
buscar otra hipótesis
ahí donde los años pasando los años 50
empezaron a decir no será la causa del
colesterol y le echaron la culpa el
colesterol porque no querían ver cuál
era la realidad con el pasar de los años
a las comidas le empezaron a sacar las
grasas pero si el colesterol es lo que
nos está enfermando le empezaron a sacar
las grasas empezaron a cada vez más ir
contra el colesterol en los años 80
aproximadamente viene el boom viene la
moda de la comida descremada de los
productos descremados sin grasa light
dietéticos pero qué pasa cuando uno le
saca la grasa a los alimentos pierden el
gusto entonces qué ha pasado ahí ahí se
le ha agregado azúcar y edulcorantes y
aditivos entonces desde el año 80 82 más
precisamente es donde se disparan
estas epidemias que tenemos hoy en día
es ahí donde crece el sobrepeso la
obesidad la diabetes el cáncer si desde
el año 82 cuando antes estas
enfermedades no la teníamos como
epidemia que es lo que ocurre no te vas
inflamar por un día pero fíjense cómo
nos estamos manejando la mayoría de los
días te levantas y tenés tu primer tu
primer desayuno que consumir ok ese
infusiones que te damos seguramente ya
tiene azúcar ya tiene aditivos recuerden
que el azúcar tiene más de 56 nombres
cuando hablamos azúcar también nos
referimos a los edulcorantes los
edulcorantes como por ejemplo el jarabe
de fructosa de maíz sucralosa los
aditivos que tienen como el aspartamo si
el glutamato monosódico son altamente
adictivos esto si usted levantas a
primera hora del día tomas tu primera
infusión y le agregas algo que también
te eleva el azúcar en sangre algo con
harinas algo con azúcar algo dulce el
problema que eso no tiene nutrientes
entonces tu cerebro nunca leyó que tenia
nutrient entonces te vas a trabajar
a las dos horas por tu ritmo de vida en
el que estamos viviendo acelerados a las
dos horas necesita cosas tenemos que
parar a las diez la mañana entonces que
vuelves a comer alguna infusión que le
agregas azúcar o edulcorante vuelves a
comer algo que te eleva el azúcar en
sangre y como no volviste a comer
nutrientes lo más probable que a las dos
horas vuelvas a tener hambre entonces
volvés a almorzar que almorzar algo que
contiene harinas algo que contiene
azúcares y encima te compras algo al
lado una bebida azucarada luego viene la
colación a la tarde tienes que parar si
no olvidarte no había hecho creer que si
no paraba la tarde nos moríamos y luego
volvés a cenar o sea que fíjense cinco
veces al día estamos generando que
nuestro organismo se inflamen porque
comemos productos que nos están
generando esta inflamación problema no
es un día fíjense a la semana 35 veces
te estás inflamando fíjate al mes 140
veces nadie te daño solamente vos con tu
ritmo de vida con lo que estás
consumiendo
fíjate al año 1680 veces que los 10 años
16 mil 800 veces los pases y ustedes se
ponen a pensar en los últimos 10 años de
su vida no ha pasado un día un día que
no hayan dejado de comer algo que
contenía azúcares edulcorante un día 10
años un día imagínense los últimos 20
años su vida entonces no hay manera que
tu organismo esté sano si todos los días
lo inundan todos los días lo inundan con
tóxicos pero fijate vos si volvés a
comer comida natural entonces te
levantas y como es comida real cuál es
la comida real la que teníamos siempre
la naturaleza carnes verduras huevos
manteca frutos secos licuados verdes si
en el desayuno comes comida real
entonces tu cerebro le recibe la
información de que comiste nutrientes
entonces lo más probable que hasta el
mediodía no vuelvas a tener hambre con
buena infusión de tomando agua pero sin
endulzantes
si esto es al mediodía vuelves a comer
comida real carne de todo tipo verduras
de todo tipo web o manteca palta comida
natural entonces tu cerebro va a leer
que comiste nutrientes y vas a llegar a
la cena si volvemos a comer de esta
manera y con comida que no nos inflama
fíjense al año cuántas veces vas a ver
reducido su inflamación 672 veces pero
los 10 años vas a haber bajado 6 mil 720
veces tu inflamación y esa es la manera
que protejas a tu cuerpo y es importante
que tomes en cuenta eso porque esto no
repercute solamente en vos repercute en
los que viven con vos pero sobre todo
repercute en tus hijos porque fíjate
mira tu hijo se levanta le prepara el
desayuno fíjate lo que pusiste en la
taza tiene aditivos tiene agregados el
nombre que bo elijas encima abuela
agrega este azúcar si le diste algo que
te elevaba el azúcar en sangre y le
pusiste algo dulce 7 de la mañana 6
media 7 lo mandas a la escuela a los 80
minutos tienen el primer recreo que
vuelven a consumir los chicos las
escuela
aguas endulzadas agua con azúcar
galletitas dulces caramelos chicles o
sea lo volvemos a llenar de azúcar
recuerden los recreos están hechos para
que los chicos tengan recreos mentales
no estaban fisiológicamente preparados
para que cada 80 minutos le demos
comidas que son altamente inflamatorias
luego viene el segundo recreo y le dimos
plata también para que vuelvan a comprar
bebidas endulzadas harinas azúcares
luego viene el tercero el almuerzo que
le damos las escuelas en el almuerzo
comida que nos eleva el azúcar en sangre
harina harina con lo que lleva al lado
con bebidas endulzadas con bebidas con
aditivos y después los padres los
llevamos a los clubes en los clubes como
queremos que nuestros nuestros hijos
sean profesionales y andy ellis que le
damos bebidas deportivas con azúcar y
luego le volvemos a dar las la cena osea
fíjense cuántas veces le estamos dando
de comer a nuestros hijos por día 7
veces
que siete veces está inflamando a tu
hijo siete veces pero fíjate a la semana
49 veces estás dañando a tu hijo y al
mes
196 veces y al año dos mil trescientos
cincuenta y dos veces pues si ustedes se
ponen a pensar en el último año
solamente le han dado bebidas endulzadas
azúcares edulcorantes y harinas y mira
los 10 años 23 mil 500 veces no hay
manera que tu hijo esté saludable de
manera que esté sano el único que está
dañando a nuestros hijos somos los
padres el único nadie viene y lo daña
pero los padres cuando vamos a las
escuelas o los clubes hacen un lío
bárbaro nuestro hijo se cae se golpea
porque se cayó porque se golpeó o qué
inflamación aguda o sea se golpeó
inflamación aguda se recupere se terminó
que no está inflamando todos los días de
tu vida los últimos diez años del
problema que a tu hijo desde que nació
le estás dando azúcares y edulcorantes
desde que nació podríamos decir también
desde desde el útero materno porque las
madres están consumiendo cada vez más
azúcar recuerda los chicos de 0 a 2 años
necesitan cero azúcar cero y nosotros
los estamos inundando pero fíjate si a
tu hijo ahora le da de comer natural o
sea que levanta y le da comida natural
huevos manteca no conozco a ningún chico
todavía que no le gusta el coco manteca
huevo manteca
panceta frutos secos lo que quieras
natural de campo no va a tener hambre a
los 80 minutos y a los 80 minutos en el
primer recreo le damos agua y que
jueguen los chicos necesitan jugar para
recrearse si no necesitan azúcar luego
viene el recreo del medio le das comida
natural hacerle un paquete con fruta un
tupper con fruta dales frutos secos dale
botellas que no tengan endulzantes luego
almuerzan y luego cenan mira al año
cuántas veces vas a bajar la inflamación
tu hijo mil ocho veces y a los diez años
diez mil ochenta veces
nadie daña tanto a tus hijos como lo que
le estás dando de comer lo que pasa que
estamos trasladando lo que era
socialmente aceptado en aquel momento
estamos repitiendo la historia en los
años 60 a los años 70 lo socialmente
aceptado en el cigarrillo y hoy lo
socialmente aceptado son las bebidas
endulzadas y los productos que contienen
azúcares si ustedes recuerdan la foto de
sus padres cuando en aquella época se
juntaban en familia o los cumpleaños
todo el mundo fumaba bueno el 80% pero
todo en la foto con cigarrillo o sea que
había más cigarrillos en la mesa que
personas fíjense la foto que ustedes
tienen en las redes sociales este fin de
semana o el fin de semana que pasó nos
juntamos a comer con amigos
con cumpleaños y hay más botellas con
azúcares de todos los colores que
personas estamos repitiendo la misma
historia
el problema que cuando fuma vamos en los
años 60 a los años 70 y 80 empezábamos a
fumar luego lo usted de los 13 años
luego los 14 15 si quieres
hoy a tus hijos desde que nacen le estás
dando azúcar le estás dando edulcorante
por eso tenemos esta piel de los chicos
porque no nadie los daños tanto como
nosotros las personas y por favor
empiecen a proteger a sus hijos y denle
la chance hoy vamos a los cumpleaños a
los chicos a los cumpleaños y no le
dimos la chance de elegir agua todos
colores las bebidas que quieras todo
azúcares por qué porque los padres
queremos festejar los cumpleaños como
festejamos los padres los chicos
recuerden van a los cumpleaños jugar van
a divertirse no conozco ningún chico que
diga quiero ir al cumpleaños porque va
haber bebidas endulzadas porque va a
haber mesa con dulce no somos los padres
son las madres que compiten entre
ustedes para ver quién hace más mesa de
dulces piensen los chicos
denle la posibilidad de que coman comida
real y es ahí donde dijimos con mis
señores si lo pensamos al revés no
tendremos que nosotros ir a preguntarle
a mis pacientes de 90 años qué hicieron
ellos para vivir 90 años sanos sanos
porque en aquella época te morías sano
pero nos estamos enfermando antes y ahí
donde volvimos a repasar en segundo año
la facultad hay un libro una materia muy
importante para nosotros que se llama
fisiología médica y en fisiología médica
nos habían enseñado que el 60 por ciento
del cerebro los nervios y la mielina es
derivado de los lípidos que son grasas
saludables el 60 por ciento de la leche
materna es derivada de las grasas las
membranas celulares que son fosfolípidos
son derivados de las grasas saludables
si las hormonas femeninas estrógeno
progesterona las hormonas masculinas
como la testosterona son derivados de
las grasas la vitamina d que es tan
importante en la prevención de cáncer es
derivado de las grasas son más grasa
entonces la pregunta es
porque prohibimos las grasas porque los
primos ok hay una pequeña porción del
colesterol mal llamado colesterol malo
que ese colesterol ldl cuando se une al
azúcar el azúcar lo inflama lo oxida y
esa sld el oxidado de que se va a
depositar en las arterias
previamente inflamadas sobre todo por el
azúcar hoy sabemos que el 30 por ciento
de los pacientes con problemas
cardiovasculares con enfermedad
coronaria con infartos son diabéticos y
el 70% restante tienen alteración
metabolismo de la glucosa esto es lo que
tenemos que cambiar es dejar de ver a
alguien que nunca tuvo nada que ver si
queremos frenar esta epidemia tenemos
que cambiar el nombre no tendremos
ningún paciente internado con
diagnóstico de colesterol y tenemos la
crisis en salud porque los hospitales no
dan abasto de pacientes con diabetes y
sus complicaciones amputación de pierna
insuficiencia renal
infartos accidente cerebrovascular y
nosotros seguimos mirando para otro lado
no hay manera que paremos esto entonces
por favor a partir de hoy deja de
dañarte deja de mirar para otro lado
cambiamos tus hábitos si mejoramos tu
salud si queremos un mundo saludable si
quieres tu familia saludable tus hijos
saludable una escuela saludable primero
tienes que cambiar bus
porque tus hijos te van a copiar esto
muy fácil
los chicos copian entonces generar un
ambiente para tener una casa saludable
para tener una escuela saludable y
clubes saludables hoy sabemos el 60 por
ciento de los chicos que mandamos los
club entraron club la última vez el 60
tiene sobrepeso pero andan con las
bebidas endulzadas porque el azúcar es
adictivo y los edulcorantes también y
andan pateando una pelota con la gaseosa
en la mano entonces por favor
tenemos que mejorar nosotros no tenemos
que venir a decir de afuera que tiene
que hacer cambien la visión de la
palabra epidemia tenemos que cambiar el
problema lo tenés en tu casa en tu
comida de todos los días por favor no te
dan es más no te infla mes más pero
sobre todo no dañes más a tus hijos
porque ellos no se lo merecen muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a
y
[Música]